a market in northern Bangkok every
morning brother Suleiman Rafiq come here
to stock up on fresh ingredients for
their Street food carts but Suleiman
Rafiq ur not their real names and they
don't want to show their faces on camera
the two men are or hinder refugees they
fled their home in western Myanmar on
the border to Bangladesh seeking refuge
in Thailand illegally Rafiq came here
several years ago by land his brother
Salim arrived in 2013 like many other o
Hinda he came by boat hella life at home
had become unbearable was a lot e which
I'm out of eating a mother when I went
to the fields to work I was often
attacked by local gangs they kicked me
and beat me with their fists and what
sticks also we were discriminated
against at school they told us your
foreigners this is not your country AHA
vide often their harvest was stolen
Salim says by local gangs but also by
the military the light out of my
recommended to daughter I had many
sleepless nights Isabelle them are very
low vision doc at night they would come
and burn down houses are like Diana they
poured gasoline on her homes and set
them on fire I lived in constant fear
that way at home Salim starts preparing
the dough for the fried bread he sells
on the streets of Bangkok for many row
Hinda here this is their only source of
income he tells me about his flight from
Myanmar the two weeks he spent at sea
with hundreds of others on one rusty
boat hungry beaten and deprived of all
dignity
he has little knowledge of the light
delivered any more alive at night they
would take the women to another room and
then we heard their screams anything the
women never spoke about what happened
they were so ashamed not everyone
survived the journey once the refugees
reached the Thai coast they were taken
to a camp in the jungle then the
traffickers demanded a ransom in
exchange for their prisoners Salim's
parents sold everything they owned to
save their son's life they told me if we
don't get the money you'll die here we
won't let you go it doesn't matter to us
what happens to you la nina nina i saw
one or two people die every day those of
us who were still strong enough had to
bury their bodies got kool-aid of hard
if I got Salim survived but for his
family back home the situation grows
more desperate with every passing day
Celine believes there is only one
solution they have to be granted
citizenship rights in Myanmar but so far
there is no sign that the Myanmar
government is ready to end the plight of
the row Hinda any time soon